in some parts of the world covet 19
restrictions are being rolled back or
even lifted completely
but in many places case numbers are
rising rapidly again making the search
for effective vaccines and treatments as
important as ever
in colombia researchers are testing a
protein-based medication other
researchers are looking into alternative
vaccines and better protective equipment
meanwhile in uganda gender inequality
has worsened during the pandemic
but first we head to india where
infection rates have been climbing again
for the last few weeks
this mahala or community clinic is a
primary health care center which
provides free basic health care
it's one of hundreds of centres in the
capital city of delhi mostly located in
low-income neighborhoods
during the city's coveted waves these
clinics played a crucial role in raising
awareness and providing timely diagnosis
now some of these centers are set to
provide covet 19 vaccinations
dr gohar azad works in one of the city's
mahala clinics
people used to feel a little hassled
when they had to line up at big centers
or hospitals this move of getting shots
at mohalla clinics will be beneficial
and we will see more and more people
come forward as now it will be much
easier to access
the past few weeks have seen a steady
uptick in the number of covert cases in
india
according to public health officials a
large majority of the population has
received two vaccines but only eight
percent of those eligible for booster
shots have gotten them
dr k srinath reddy says it's not just
about the ease of getting a booster shot
there's also a perception that the
omicron variant of the virus won't
result in severe illness
as well as the belief that the vaccine
won't prevent infections from happening
in the first place
but he adds that it's important to keep
encouraging people to get the booster
shot
because it can prevent a large number of
infections from becoming severe
too
if the severity of infection is low
then the amount of virus discharge is
going to be much less
because the duration of illness is also
going to be much less so you pose a less
of a threat to others especially
elderly vulnerable people in your
household or your family
even though most of the cases happening
now are mild to moderate the fact that
people are getting infected despite
being vaccinated or having recovered
from an infection is proof enough that
they need all the protection they can
get against this virus the pandemic in
india is nowhere near over
covet 19 has not only had a massive
impact on the global economy but also on
gender equality
in uganda more girls than boys have
dropped out of school than the pandemic
and many women have lost their jobs
beyond that police say that domestic
violence against women is on the rise
[Music]
we come to the district of cabarola in
western uganda
fiona cansimi was a high school student
before she got pregnant during the
two-year lockdown
the 20-year-old now has to balance
farming and caring for her
nine-month-old baby
when you get pregnant people say that
you brought it on yourself
they think the man has little to do with
it
he never
they say that if he approaches you and
you refuse do you get pregnant
no you don't
in ugandan schools many female students
didn't return after the lockdown
teacher ruth tassimi says that many
families stop girls education if they
get pregnant
for them they think that
when a girl has just had has got
pregnant or given birth that is the end
what
what comes in their mind is that
he or she can she should go to the
father of that child or get married to
any other any other man because
they think
that that is the end of her
when it comes to the socio-economic
impact the united nations says that
women are more affected by disease
outbreaks than men
jolessi masika says that when her
partner wanted money during the lockdown
he sold the family's only home and
farmland without her
[Music]
sold everything at home
including the house and farmland
and he resorted to drinking
now i'm struggling to pay the rent
without a stable job
furthermore ugandan police precincts
reported that domestic violence rose by
almost 30 percent in the first year of
the pandemic the country's crime report
for the two years of kovid 19 shows that
on average a woman was killed every 48
hours due to family disputes sparked by
alcoholism
people tend to think by drinking
they put off their stress
and others drink excessively and lose
their reasoning that's why they end up
fighting assaulting children
then there are people who we have
different cultures who still perceive
that a man is ahead and
whatever he does is right
culturally speaking many traditional
norms in uganda discriminate against
women
when families lost members to covet 19
many girls and women shared the agony of
losing their loved ones but didn't
inherit a fair share of the family's
wealth
actually there are some people who
lives without making
a will
and that one becomes a problem to the
people who will give out the properties
of the deceased
when the father has not mentioned that
my cow is given to my child that will
not be given
it will just be given to only
men
when the
father maybe has written a will
and the emotion is emotion is that my
daughters will be given this that's when
they give them but everything is given
to
to to
men
around the world activists want women's
rights to be protected in the pandemic
they say it's everyone's responsibility
to protect the most vulnerable so that
women like kansimi can receive the
support they need so that they and their
children have quality of life
what do you think of when you hear the
word vaccination probably about rolling
up your sleeve and getting a needle in
your arm
but many researchers believe there's a
more effective way to give people
protection against the kovid 19 virus
we spoke to virologist and academic
jonathan gershone from tel aviv
university about the future of nasal
vaccines
when you're given a standard set of
covet 19 vaccines via injection it kicks
off a response in the cells nearby
causing your immune system to begin
producing antibodies against the
coronavirus invader
in other parts of your body the
production of longer term protective
cells called memory t cells and b cells
begins creating what's known as systemic
immunity the response
is to generate
antibodies
of the class igg immunoglobulin g
that are able to recognize the
infectious agent and knock it out and
this is done at the port of entry that
is to say the muscle or the blood or in
our liver and so on and so forth so that
is the systemic immunity
with the systemic immunity that injected
vaccines provoke the protective
components are spread throughout the
body's systems
exposure to sars cov2 however happens in
a specific place the upper respiratory
tract and the protective cells and
antibodies can take some time to respond
to it
the antibodies that are produced
systemically
work pretty good
in clearing
infectious agents systemically
but when we have a situation
that the point of entry
is in our mucosa
in the lining of our nose throat lungs
and guts
then the level of the antibodies there
may not be sufficient
one way to amp up the response would be
to apply vaccines via a spray directly
to the area where respiratory bugs get
into the body
that would create a more localized
protection where it's needed most the
port of entry kind of like putting
guards at the front door of a house to
fend off intruders rather than in the
attic or the basement
this is called mucosal immunity because
it's created in the membranes exposed
directly to the outside world the
membranes are packed with a special
antibody called iga
if you could stimulate
an effective dose of iga
that same protective antibody but is
targeted to the port of entry to the
mucosa
then it should be markedly more
effective in preventing infection
of those viruses that enter through the
mucosa such as respiratory viruses such
as corona
other advantages that nasal sprays have
over injections include not having to
train personnel as intensely to apply
them and of course they take needles out
of the process entirely nobody likes
those
so
why don't we have nasal vaccines already
what's the holdup
there are a number of complications so
there is some
amount
of protective immunity in our nose not
sufficient
from prior exposure there is
a lesser efficiency intake of the
vaccine the pre-existing immunity is
viewing the entry of the vaccine as
something it somewhat recognizes not
very efficient and it's reducing the
effective dose and level
of immunization it's complicated
and more difficult to produce more
difficult to to get regulatory we have
less experience
getting the amounts right is a big
technical challenge
in the nasal cavity we have secretion we
sneeze not everything is being absorbed
there are celia there are these
hair-like structures that are clearing
fluids and and reducing
the dose the amount of actual vaccine
material that we want to target
to our immune system
despite those hurdles progress is being
made in the field more than a dozen
candidates are currently in clinical
trials a few are pretty far along
[Music]
we do see encouraging results
my assumption is
that in the completion of a phase three
clinical trial
there will be a push to try to introduce
the vaccine
and so this could be i would hope within
the coming next half a year or year
because so many people have already been
vaccinated via injection any nasal
vaccines approved in the future will in
most cases provide updates to protection
by kick-starting mucosal immunity
supplementing the underlying systemic
immunity provided by injections it's an
approach experts call prime and spike
on a background of a systemic response
we can introduce a nasal response to
fortify
the systemic protection which blocks
severe disease
with
reduction
of local infection and later
transmission
although there are still hurdles that
nasally administered coveted vaccines
must clear many experts are optimistic
at least some will one day see wide use
because they'll make getting regular
boosters also to other respiratory
diseases a simple and painless process
while some researchers are working to
develop new vaccines others are focusing
on improving protective measures for
example scientists in spain have
developed a mask that alerts users when
its co2 content gets too high
[Music]
since the pandemic outbreak in early
2020 masks have become an indispensable
ally in preventing the spread of covet
19.
but in spite of the evidence in favor of
them in reducing community transmission
people who have to wear a mask for hours
on end agree that it's not always easy
some days especially at the start of the
pandemic i had a headache and felt
drowsy
since you can't breathe as well and
you're working all day you may get more
tired than usual
the co2 concentration between a person's
face and an ffp2 mask is higher than
usual because the air that's exhaled
gets trapped inhaling this carbon
dioxide can lead to health effects such
as headache or fatigue
when i wear the mask for a long time and
it's busy i get tired and my nose and
throat get dry
i have to run to the kitchen drink water
breathe a bit and get back to work
to help mask wearers avoid these issues
a multi-disciplinary research team made
up of engineers and chemical scientists
from the university of granada has
developed an intelligent mask that
alerts wearers on their smartphones when
recommended co2 limits are exceeded
the intelligent mask has a sensor
meaning a way to measure something in
the air between your face and the mask
so this co2 sensor is equipped with the
electronics that will measure the color
change in the sensor
and transmit that information to a
smartphone
so a standard ffp2 mask can be turned
into an intelligent mask that monitors
gas concentration by placing a special
electronic sticker inside the mask
the sticker inserted inside the mask is
a system that consists of two parts
on one side there's what's called
readout electronics which is printed
with conductive ink on a flexible
plastic and transparent substrate as you
can see
on the other side is the chemical part
of the sensor that changes its color
depending on the co2 concentration
to notify users if they've reached the
recommended co2 limits inside the mask
the research team has designed a special
mobile app
the user has a mobile app to read the
carbon dioxide concentration
with nfc technology
the same technology used for wireless
payments
users would simply have to hold their
smartphone close to the mask
it automatically detects this sticker
and reads the co2 concentration inside
the mask
the software alerts users through a
traffic light display red or green if
they need to ventilate
although mask mandates have been lifted
in many countries many workers are still
required to wear them so the researchers
believe there's a demand
the team is willing to transfer the
technology to any industry that may be
interested in it
and like every week dw science
correspondent derek williams answers
your questions about the latest research
you can write to him at covetproducer
dw.com
[Music]
this week an anonymous viewer wanted to
know what's the rebound effect that can
occur after taking antiviral treatments
to explain this phenomenon we first have
to talk about pax levitt the antiviral
drug made by pfizer
which works by inhibiting an enzyme that
sars cov2 needs
to make copies of itself in other words
if that enzyme is blocked
it stops the virus from replicating
properly um trials showed
that giving the drug to people in the
first five days after covid19 symptoms
appeared
cut their chances of being hospitalized
dramatically
that in turn has led healthcare
authorities to clear the way for its
widespread use particularly in patients
who are elderly
or who are immunocompromised or who have
pre-existing conditions that might put
them at high risk if they contract the
disease
pax-livid treatment involves taking a
lot of pills the full courses is 30 of
them over five days and often
by the end of it patients are testing
negative on antigen tests but then
what's called the rebound effect can
complicate the picture um most people
who take those 30 pills will experience
less severe symptoms than those who
don't take them but
in some people
some studies say around 1 in 20
but maybe more
the disease rebounds that means a few
days after being squashed
the symptoms and viral loads can bounce
back and patients can start testing
positive again
that happened to my mother for one but
it also happened to the top medical
advisor in the u.s anthony falci
and of course more recently to american
president joe biden
it's not really clear exactly why the
disease can rebound some experts think
it happens if the virus
is suppressed by the medication too
early in the infection um kind of
denying the immune system the chance to
really get to know the virus well
and develop enough tools against it
others think that some people might just
harbor reservoirs of the virus in their
bodies
in in places that the drug can't reach
another idea is that some people could
be breaking down the drug faster than
others which would give it less time to
accomplish its mission
and maybe open the door to a resurgence
when the pills are stopped
regardless
the medical advice about what to do if
you have a rebound case of covet after
taking paxlivit
is still really
muddy anthony fauci
for instance took a second course of the
drug but my mom was told not to
both recovered from their rebounds
quickly
what everyone does agree on is that
we'll need more studies to really figure
out things like
optimal dosage and and duration of
treatment
researchers in other countries are also
developing drugs to combat the
coronavirus
for example scientists in colombia are
working on a protein-based treatment
that's intended to lessen the impact of
covid19 on the body
[Music]
when covet 19 hit colombia many
researchers at this biotechnology
institute dropped other projects to
focus on it and one promising idea could
lead to a possible therapy for the
disease it involves using blocker
proteins to mimic a large enzyme called
ace2 it's where the coronavirus docks on
to break in
apart once you have that knowledge you
can start cutting out the minimum
necessary parts of the ace2 protein
those are the ones that interact with
the viruses spike protein
that's how i started cutting out these
sections
we've now designed about 200 different
versions of what we're calling mini
ace2s
these mini ace2s interact with the virus
in different ways could some of them
reduce its ability to dock onto
vulnerable cells the colombian
researchers ran models of molecular
dynamics and discovered promising
candidates
yeah i say this as well our comparisons
showed that three of those proteins were
very interesting because one had three
times the interaction strength compared
to natural ace2
the second had 20 times the strength and
the last had 40 times the interaction
strength
so the virus's spike protein binds more
efficiently to the blocker proteins than
it does to human cells could that be
used to create an effective medicine
paulino gomez decided to support the
investigation
back when the whole world was searching
for solutions everyone had their own
ideas about the best ways to fight
against sars ko v2 in our lab we were
searching for small molecules that might
be effective against it but didn't have
much success i found cesar's approach
very interesting it comes at the problem
from a different angle and we decided to
go with it
the blocker proteins are churned out by
genetically engineered yeast
it's a relatively cheap technique to
employ
and researchers at a nearby institute
have used it to explore other proteins
and told me he had some candidates that
we would work on to develop an
alternative treatment for covert 19 i
looked forward to transferring our
experience with other proteins other
diseases to this much more global
disease the work could potentially have
a much greater impact that was very
motivating
the project won a local award receiving
funding that speeded up the research
process it also gave the scientists a
regular income which is far from
guaranteed in colombia
participating in a project as ambitious
as this one which could potentially
contribute to scientific knowledge in
general both on the global stage and in
the current pandemic that has given me a
lot of pride
the blocker protein models that were
digitally designed then produced will
next move into testing in human cells
the researchers could hit some speed
bumps at this critical stage
it isn't easy in colombia to import the
necessary reagents the treatment would
be intended for people who have active
covet infections
it would be given to those who've been
infected so someone who's tested
positive for the virus
they would receive the blocker protein
to inhibit the viruses that are
circulating in their bodies or that have
multiplied in affected
blocker would prevent those viruses from
continuing to infect more cells
the goal is to create an effective
treatment for combating the corona virus
but the research is also providing
fundamental insights into a possible new
approach to fighting other diseases
[Music]
we hope this episode could bring you up
to date on treatments against covet 19
and the pandemic's ongoing impact
hope to see you again next time
until then take care and stay healthy
[Music]
you